so what we've got here is four graphs -
each represent four different situations
and the important thing is that you can
see what each one means you can move the
line and think of okay I can interpret
this I see what it signifies so let's
have a look at each one of those
descriptions and then see which one it
best matches to so the first situation
is a lot of fun payment is made during
the period of the loan so these are all
repayments so that's why things are
going down if you make a blob sub all at
one time what would that look like on
the graph what direction is it going you
it's going to go to go down right
because you're paying off so you'll have
less than a debt so which of these
graphs has one of those yes the last one
right so you can see this is just a
regular repayment and this is what
happens if at a certain moment BAM you
know you with a lot or something like
that you can pay that off suddenly and
then the rest of your periods carry on
does that make sense so that's what's
going to match up to Part A and Part B
during the period of the loan that Boris
starts making hiring payments than the
ones needed to powerful own new green
period of time so degree preview times
always set up 25 years 30 years
something like that
come in volume
anyone else that was very graceful
elegant yes yes correct so you can see
graph what in each situation is
identical so this is what a normal
situation looks like just like we looked
at in this question here okay by the way
I will also point out but it might be
easier to see on this one feel I want
you to look at something which is if
they asked for Q but it's an important
question anyway I want you to look at
the gradient can you look at the
gradient as you progress from left to
right just forget about the orange
reference I can just look at the blue
one particularly do you notice how to
see each of these dots it you need not
they're spaced out at regular intervals
what up what are the regular tools every
I think it's just after 50 that's at 60
what's the significance of 65 years okay
so these doctor every five years now
what should you compare these two dots
are the extra dots and they're vertical
distance just compare that and then I
want you to compare these two dots at
their vertical distance think about this
each of them represents a five year
slice of time horizontally but
vertically they're quite different this
one's like little here and then this one
I can barely make my pen stress that but
why is that why did such a difference
okay say that again slowly as you pay
what happen
as you pay yes below for that one the
total is less yep
therefore
that your pain is going to be bigger
fractions with you okay okay let me say
that again because that was exactly you
got there in the end okay
Oh as you pay as time progresses the
actual size of the loan is getting more
come in and I just really people are
good eliezer to be of it yeah sure
anywhere else Thanks I bet you are okay
so the question is about interest rate
I'll come to that question in a second
the person indicas pointed out is if
you've got a smaller loan but you keep
on repeating like look see over here it
says you keep repeating the same amount
over here again but the loan itself is
smaller so proportionally it what to be
getting faster right but that's not
actually the main thing the main thing
is pinterest we come back over here
right see that's really really slow at
the beginning it's the way all loans go
and it's super depressing I remember the
first time when I got my mortgage I
think I was paying two thousand one
hundred dollars a night or something
like that and I think about 1900 of that
1900 out of 2,100 was interest so what
actual debt oddsmaker was tiny that's
what's happening up here the interest is
really large because the loan is
enormous at the beginning but it sort of
slides down like this because at the end
you're Lotus board which means your
interest is also small does that make
sense okay so when you come back over
the office we're trying to now think
about this higher repayment situation
they're paying more than they originally
agreed to it's sort of like this in fact
so which situation is it which one
represents for the orange line faster
repeated at the blue moon
this is a it's like this exactly what
this graph look like when we did a
couple minutes here okay Part C now this
is going to raise an interesting
question for us there's an interest-only
period then regular payments are made
so in other words for a brief amount of
time they don't get charged interests
and then they start paying okay which
one is that I think I heard it this is
see okay this is see now how can we tell
maybe look a little closer on you if
there's an interest rate period right
that means that this balance owing isn't
being made larger by the constant adding
interest okay so therefore you can see
it's just sort of flat here if you hear
it adds when it's like interest free for
two years or something like that this is
what's going on okay and then you can
see the payments get made and you still
end up at the same time over sorry the
same amount over the same period of time
okay now I wanted to point out this
range is something really important
because this situation here Part C this
situation is sometimes actually done on
purpose by design especially by anyone
who is renting we've talked about this
some people ask the informal questions
for why would you rent if you can
actually pay off something like actually
have a mortgage in that kind of thing
the reason why is you don't have enough
money so what does the landlord get out
of this well they'll often buy a
property so they'll borrow this huge
amount of money okay but then they never
intend to pay it off let me say that
again they'll borrow this huge amount of
money to like get deposit okay they
don't pay off they then get someone so
they get a tenant to rent it and then
they put in money so it looks like this
it's not an interest-free period it's
just that all of that rental money is
coming in and it's just going straight
to paying off the interest so this is
what the graph will look like okay now
why on earth would you get a loan if you
never intend to take off the loan why
don't you do that what would be the
advantage of doing this yeah
so what we're hoping is that debt does
this like the debt stays level but we
hope that the property does not stay a
little bit actually increase in value
okay
so at some point in the future the
landlord's just going to sell the place
right they're still got all the original
debt which they've got to pay off but
then hopefully their property is worth
more now like so there will be a net
profit did that make sense this is a
really important idea to get across
because that's the way investments work
basically okay I've lost one event I'd
like to have a go at these it's the last
one so the last graph anyway so you know
what the answer is for the first three
years the monthly repairs are less than
the interest on the loan so this person
is not actually successfully paying on
what they agreed to and then regular
your payments are made so can you
explain to me why our last graph
demonstrate that what's going on what
why do you bring up why is it going up
because he's our pay enough if he's not
paying up the problem with not paying
enough is that the interest keeps
growing right like if it just stayed
level even if they paid it slower it
will just be a slower graph right but
the problem is not that you're not me
actually
the interest is taking over and
overcoming the pay that you're making as
you can see it goes up at this curvy way
because that's what compound interest
does and then finally they have to
recover so you can see there are many
more payments that have to be made in
one more okay so this is to see how to
read particularly how much you owe
whether goes up or down versus time and
whether you want to compare something
which I think in the previous question
you know the whole point with that ended
sooner right so have a look at these
next two questions just be really
careful when you read these things you
because often your pants will depend on
interpreting that and sometimes the dots
as we pointed out don't always line up
with exactly where you'd expect it to
okay